you've been doing a stand-up comedy tour
across the nation we bought a house and
I have to pay for the remodel so I've
been doing a lot of stand-up but I have
this problem where I strangely want the
audience's to hate me and I don't I
think that's why I host the soup just so
I can spew ridicule and I was playing
the Grand Old Opry in Nashville famous
famous famous famous for stand-up comedy
[Music]
it's a literally a church and I can't
help myself so I walked out I was like
hello
don't you idiots realize country music
sucks and what yeah why did you do that
I had to it can't I have no choice my
brain just says say it now you do have a
choice but they strange really like ah
we're gonna kill you and and then then I
brought up some of their like I I go I
know you don't think you're racist but
you guys have that one instrument that
sound you know that thing you're gonna
bear me don't like that thing you know
what that's called a Jews harp it's
literally a je w ' harp you could change
the name of that instrument yes and
they're like we don't want to Joe and so
we're happy with who we are we're
terrific and I I don't
what about when you go you must go other
places where you you don't insult them
no I mean really everywhere you go like
I was in Montreal and those people are
really really rude because they don't
speak English and now they have this
thing where if you're in Montreal and
you walk into a store they speak French
and you walk into a store and English
and you walk in and you go hide like a
cup of coffee they will go they will you
don't those are French words right but
if you attempt French if you're like
multiple sales home but then they go
like what do you want and it's so I
walked out and it was a television
special and it was a bunch of comics I
was hosting it and it was in Montreal
and I said good evening Tehran
and and they don't like Toronto they
hates Toronto I swear they like Isis
more than Toronto because they famous
had to stop cameras were turned off and
they're like Joel you cannot do that and
they're like you must like it's in your
country and they're like and I was like
it was so I was like you can drive to it
that's how they all talk it is very weak
more angry they did the less air they
put over the vocal cords when they're
really mad there's just nothing only a
dog can hear at home I just feel the air
from their mouth coming out it's
incredible yo you okay yeah I'm a jerk
you're a jerk you're bad and I feel a
bad bad man that's what we've
established hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please